this is a production of cornell
university
well thank you thank you and dr
nielsen for giving me this opportunity
to introduce my work
so the topic today as we just mentioned
i put a question mark on that especially
the genome because i don't really know
the answer
hopefully people in the audience give
them some
idea so because many of you are
not working cucumbers so i will first
give you a quick
uh brief introduction for the cucumber
and cucumber diseases
and the molecular mapping of food
resistances
and then i will give three examples
which uh work primarily from my lab
first
talk about the staggering gene which uh
mutation
in this gene come first the multiple dis
resistance
mdr and then i will talk about the focus
on the dynamic view
uh in two pi lines about the genetic
basis uh the generic architecture and
the complexity
and very diverse mechanisms
and the third example uh is
called we recently working on a mutation
called respect
leave which it's probably not
directorate with these resistance but
it does uh use association with
multiple dc resistance also with uh
some abiding stress tolerance
so cucumber may not feel may not be
familiar
it's cucumber sativa as it's or
the coca-pedesia family with relatively
small genocides few crumbs on footing
chromosomes
367 it's largely cross-pollinated
because it has a monitors sex expression
but it has literally inbreeding
depression
it has a short life cycle and
it has been a moderate species for a
long time
uh for successful and also vascular
biology
uh there are several marketing class
classes
as shown in these pictures in each
marketing class
market groups it has a neurogenic basis
it has been a minor crop with really
very small public research
community like many other horticulture
crops
but i you know i think it is a
profitable
uh crop and the breeding work has been
primarily done in the
private companies as many other
horticulture crops
we have already a little bit work done
even before the years ago but since then
we have seen significant approaches made
particularly in recent years uh talking
about the diseases i think
it these resistance have always been a
top priority many crops for
cucumber and i think many other carpets
are the major diseases include at least
uh mature diseases here like donnie meet
you for the first
food rot potter meet you angular you
spot hardly spot
and frag knows specimen wheeled
skeptic garment stem blight so and also
several wireless pathogens
the priority really depends on the
production system
which like in the u.s we you usually
practice
opening once you were mashing harvest
the dolly meet you and the food festival
food rot are
actually the top priority for breeding
in open field cucumber production
and for some others like the cgm
and we varus it's a new threat
for cucumber production in greenhouse
industry
but for some other like a southern rock
not nematode
it has been a problem for many years but
unfortunately we don't have any
resistance sauce in carter the cucumber
so i know they're having as i mentioned
a lot of work has been done in recent
years so molecular mapping cloning of
these
resistant genes this is a summary
in a recent review we we published
basically uh indicating that
genes and acute mapped along seven
chromosomes
uh cucumber chromosomes those radons
uh at the into wheels of
the done immediate qto on different
locations
from different styles you can see and
the green ones are porter medium
you can see the majority of the studies
focus on
uh q2 mapping don and meet you and uh
porter meet you there are some
interesting
things you can see first you can see the
linkage of donald mediocre immediate
resistance
from their colloquialization
on the chromosomes which is true because
cucumbers have seen this for a long time
you when you are developing a variety
without immediate resistance it also has
other major resistances um
also for the conservation
colloquialization of the facility
wheeled scalp resistance and
wireless resistances also
you can see the majority most many genes
for these resistance
are located on chromosome 5 and s
also chromosome six uh these are
uh some interesting uh
probably i don't know that it may relate
to the
evolution history of the chromosomes
and of course also there are more than
100 genes qt was identified very few had
been cloned here is a list of 15 genes
which we know the candid gene
uh some of those are are
not really functional when they did it
but i think
reasonably the candid gene probably
cracked
of these half of them are done
immediately in the product meet you
the system you can see uh the dominicu
the this this column are some
the functions three of the
the staggering gene which contribute to
resistance across three pathogens
and also down to meet you you can see
all these
uh three photon meteor resistance
resistant chronic are different
there are four genes for potential
which are people probably more familiar
with these
kinase or mo genes so
i'm going to focus on the staggering
gene and the
focus on dynamic you and us for the
microphone systems
as i mentioned for the speculative
mutation
so photonic meteor many of uh many of
you probably familiar particular people
on cue carpets with
which is the biggest threat for all the
cuckoo bits but it's particularly
uh a problem for cucumber
uh it's a homicide that the pathogen
called a pseudo
spora canvas the primary reason for this
develops so fast once you find it it's
very difficult to
control you can see that the
symptoms of monomitial
i want to emphasize that there are
chlorosis necros necrotic spots
based on the symptoms we also when we
are doing phenotyping we can use
different criteria like aspiration
like here or necrosis sometimes
called collapsing chlorosis
we can individually scroll for for the
symptom development using three criteria
but in most cases we just use carbon
general impression
which is summation of the individual
symptoms so these
are as very important to understand the
underlying genetics
of these resistance photon mitchum
so donald mitchell has an interest at
brain history which was first reported
in 1968
in cuba actually that's why it's called
occupancies
but the breeding work started here in
the u.s in
late 1940s actually the first
uh cucumber variety kind of permitted
was released in 1948
unfortunately it was breakdown two years
later
since then cucumber breeders
spend a lot more time developing
donation resistance and
in the 50 years in 2004
we have been focused on use a single
source of dynamic resistance
from the pi 197
we call it it's a single gene called dm
wang
uh like the pond stuff sirius
[Music]
which was developed by cornell cucumber
breeder
it's very famous which carries the dm
wang also
we have very well known in june platinum
called gy14
and wi-2757
these two gyms are very popular for
cucumber breeders
which carry the dm wing since 2004
uh the dm1 was no longer in fact you
fortunately identify a new source of
resistance for the new strengths
of particular two pi lines uh pi197288
and appears
through six to eight with high
resistance so these four lines are the
major packets of my presentation today
first let me talk about that on
immediate resistance in
uh the old donor medium we call it
pines757
and the gy14 as a kinder 757a
it's really a legend with which has uh
resisted nine passages which was
developed by
my predecessor dr clint patterson
after that break nine to zero four uh
north carolina state
screened the collection and in the
where cucumber radius tunisia 756 still
maintains a pretty good resistance uh
among the rarities so we
we have interest to do acute mapping uh
in qr14 and the 2nd central 57
we used the classical qt mapping studies
first we used a real population
from gy14 using the yellowing called
colossus and the gi
uh we scored that the different time
points
in multiple environments you can see in
our
experiments we see we did a single qto
which i was located on chromosome 5
which is consistent in the previous
study so
that's the dm wang we have been knowing
for a while
interestingly when you use the alloying
um
it it's it's uh in this population
um at different time how does this
future always consistently detect but it
is generally
impressing sometimes when you
later the first time you have a
high uh you can detect
the qt but a later stage it's gonna
disappear so that we
says two two two things first uh the
criteria we used
is important a second that time of
scoring also very important
but anyway in this case gr-14 contains a
single qtl which is dm1
or chromosome 5 but and also
basically it's anti-chlorosis plays a
important role in the
immediate resistance but uh in the 2757
depending on which criteria you use uh
if we use yellowing you only detect
vmware
but using a necrosis basically
you only detect a second acuity of
chromosome 5 which
we name it em 5.2
but if we use gi which is a summation of
you're going to detect the both of
course which depends on which
time power you're going to you score
so so in 2057
there is an additional qto in addition
to dmwang
this is the conclusion from uh
q2 mapping studies but in previous
uh readers also find that the tenuous
m15 and uf14
also have resistance to uh the
anthracnose
so at the time when starter work we have
new idea
uh they are actually the same genes so
we have an independent
study to map the anthrax resistance
in the two lines and there is a future
method strategy
uh true it's also uh mapped in
chromosome five
uh we named the cla but in in
2757 there are additional minor q q
the same is true for angular spots and
we use we've identified the angular spot
resistance in
gy 14 on chromosome 5 with the same
location as the dm rank
but the in 375 we find
identify additional q tiers so you you
if you
do don't actuate your analysis you're
going to find
that the m1 pseo for angular spot
and the asteroid nodes are all at
the same same location
uh this this
gene so we continue to define mapping
and
map based colony eventually we'll be
able to identify the candy gene which is
a staggering gene
uh we staggering it's
called the mechanism the challenges
plays important role in their club for
degradation
so we examined that symptom development
as
a pathogen growth and the stage engine
expression
you can see on the susceptible lines
it has a typical chlorosis symptom
and that capacity and keep growing
population keep increase but also in a
susceptible line
these genes show significant
uh increase of expression but in their
resistance lines it has a low level
expression
so consistent with our expectation of
the claw field degrading
pathway will be involved also
uh if we do the philo genetic analysis
we can see
uh this gene that
which was originated from pi197387
from india is true uh this is staggering
gene
uh that the mutant allele was origin
from pi7087 if you do
using polymorphism in a
kb region to do philogenetic analysis
you can see all the resistance will be
class
clustering when small clay
why we use kinetic kb because the aod
this region is very
high a very low high recombination
as this is really consistent with the
breeding history because
all the resistant lines carrying the dm
wing
in the u.s breeding materials
carry this uh the haplotype basically
and those surgical veins
don't so that means
this gene was under selection
during the breeding of the u.s pickling
and saucing cucumbers
and we examined all the genes in the
crop
degradation pathway i must realize
including the two resistance line and a
susceptible
line you can see consistently the
staggering
other two genes downstream of the
sticker engine pph and the po
shoot similar uh expression patterns
but those are the clock fuel a b bypass
a little bit different extreme pattern
these these expression profiles suggest
that
true that these resistance and indeed
they developed
claw field degradation but how we don't
have uh
we are still working on this and
here is basically our speculation that
in
in the susceptible way we have a
regular uh chromosomal degradation upon
infection of the disease pacifier
but uh and you have seen typical
symptoms
closest necrosis and and the disease
but in the resistance when because of
mutation a single mutation
yeah this this
a pathway was less
efficient in degradation
because the simple development
staggering is required if mutation
this medicine will block the crawford
degradation which is issues that
receives actually it's a
passive passive resistance but we don't
know if
there is any active uh resistance
because we can see the different uh
uh reactions upon uh uh infection
in in the asteroid no
and angular sport so respectfully
probably there are some active defense
uh during the interaction
but a lot of more work we need to do
so that's uh staggering story
next time we talk about that q2 mapping
studies
in two pi lines uh
upon that when you need large scale
screening using uh the
new strength uh the two pr lines
pi19738 and the six to eight should high
resistance uh
but that commercial like that comparison
are not acceptable because is a very uh
wide locking uh three three
six two eight also called uh 7120 wi
only has autonomous resistance but the
708
has both strong immediate and powerful
mutual resistance so we conducted that
keto mapping studies in the two lines
and identified the four key major uh
two immediate in fact futures in three
co2
for six to eight and
we have identified eleven creatures the
seven zero d8
and also we identified the four qt of
the potential
systems in 738 it's interesting to see
based on their confirmed locations for
all the four donor media criticism
color class between the two uh
two pi lines suggesting they may be the
same
um but uh of the 11 qt
seven zero eight eight three actually
contributed sustainability
and there are two unique major in fact q
two incentive 88
so you can see there are fewer qto's in
uh in the three three or six to eight
that means from breathing perspective
probably
this api lines three services is better
uh than the service radiate and also
for dom immediately and product meet you
put in in the
7088 you can see the four
qto's all the color class that also
suggest that linkage basically uh this
line uh
for for the boost dynamic on polymedia
resistance
because four point dm4
and the dm 5.2 are co-localized which
measure in fact qtls in both lines
through the foxes that took
your form file mapping uh the strategy
is to
just first we developed neos for
individual q2
uh to mentalize basically individual qto
and then we do segregation
uh linkage analysis multiple year
mutual location phenotyping and
that's i think most of us are familiar
with
standardized so we are able to evaluate
uh narrow down to a very small region
using multiple year phenotypic data
in the case of 4.1 uh 82 kb
that's that's based on the 2018 29 in
data
but in today
to continue data we
there are a couple recommendations which
are not consistent
that kind of gene region shift to
a different location so
that that's always true when you're
working with qto
is relatively uh not so large
in fact that we learn some important
lessons
uh but actually that's not necessarily
something wrong because recently
another group working in pi 7
0 7 0 and 888 on the dmva
they suggest there are actually some
subacute your serious subjective at the
dm
for pointman locus and
which are very closely uh
close with each other and they
identified the candy genes
for the 4.12 which is a receptor-like
kinase and 4.13 which is an amino acid
transporter
and that polymorphism is both uh
on the 551 bp insertion
or transparent insertion so we examined
our data in seven one two zero
as i mentioned before the two lines at
the four point locks
their problems here the same it is true
but we follow analysis we we probably
we think probably there are additional
additional qt or subcritical
we called the 4.01 to a and the photon
went to b
we examined the allelic diversity of the
two clone
qto for 0.12 and from n3
and that this seven one two zero
uh line also carrying that the variance
so
we think that they are are the same
uh we are focusing on cloning the 401 to
be at 4.01 uh
this is probably reasonable because 7120
was from pakistan
originally someone zero eight eight from
india which geographically not very far
away
could be reasonably speculate they have
the same
orange and
for 5.2 we do we use the same strategy
and we at this time we narrowed down 50
kb
i don't think that we have anything
wrong here and we are a couple of gs we
think
it's very possible whether we need more
data
it's likely a phosphate transporter and
another interest in seeing in 738
and the same qto also
the potential 5.2 resistance also
same location likely the same gene
contribute to boost dynamics and
potential resistance
and that's our speculation uh the third
example is about a spec
leaf which probably associated with the
market with these resistance
are we identifying uh this is visually
it's this we call it the speckled leave
because there are many clock spots
at the first second sort of true leaves
but after the fourth probably usually
in this particular line after fists when
the plant
reaches fifth through leave this clutch
spot will be gone
and we conduct genetic studies
and this mutation
is controlled by single recessive gene
we call seo
for speculative and
we grew these lines in field
that's really an intention we never find
but last
year in our field trial which
we have very serious angular spot in the
field
we find differences between the our
mutants
original donor line we call that w means
wild
means mutant and we
i calculated i mean these scores
it's a significant higher this is uh
scores for the
wider type and we find that in the end
of c then we measure that the
fruit related traits we find that are no
different and the significant
difference basically that mutants
perform
much better than the what type under the
disease procedure
after the same field they grew different
populations we found
all the plants carrying the mutant line
have better resistance than the water
that
those plants carrying the wild alleles
which is true in different
populations this suggests that the
resistance
is truly is kind of independent
of genetic background so
based on this we did summon a diffusion
collisions
uh tests in the greenhouse chambers for
example we
tested the earth's reg nose that
and you can see after even one week or
we nucleasing
this mutant the steeler
looks pretty nice and healthy but the
white up almost stayed so we did follow
uh with important media don't
meet you and attack this spot which
should
similar trend
that's for the resistance these
resistance but for the
phenotype we find some genetic
background in fact
like if we introduce that mutant allele
into
uh another cucumber line called the 99th
reader which
and we find the symptoms
of the mutant fetal phenotype
is much more strong usually in the
original line
uh the symptoms and clot spots will be
gone
uh when which is fifth true leaf but in
this
new background the very even 10 15 days
true leaves you can still see even the
flowers
and then the fruit skin you can see that
those whitish stripes
so that means this gene probably is
expression
affected by the background
and accidentally we also find that this
mute
mutant had better resist tolerance to
water stress because the grass still in
the [ __ ] of the water when
they put the plants in the greenhouses
and the farms
maybe a few weeks a few days later found
that actually
the mutant the seedlings still feel
happy even under very severe
water stress so we conducted uh us
uh expanded just just
progressively with what we draw and
unlock
the appearance of the mutant and the
wild types
and measures of what relative water
content you can see
at two different time temperature
settings
uh the mutant yes
it skips higher water content and
not less wilting compared with uh wild
type
we also did the uh salinity
stress experiment using different
concentrations of
sodium chloride and we have similar
results
so basically
what we see is the are the mutant
mutant line has a better resistance to
both these resistance multiple d
resistance and other
uh about the stress tolerance
so we clone this gene and the final
retreat from
rest in russian the first axon of the
canon gene
which resulted in the dilation of the 72
bp
uh transferred in the cdna
we did a subcellular localization of
this the protein fund it's located in
the
chloroplast the rna seeker
transcript profiling in the mutant and
what types we find as a top four guru in
which terms are
all relative with the membrane uh
biogenesis is some
so this may suggest that
this gene may function in in
biogenesis because it's located in cloud
past
some biogenesis
more specifically uh in a
protein transport from
nucleus to the chloroplast so there are
multiple pathways we know
of particular is uh cpsrp for the 350
pathway
so they're not just after
the protein since synthesized in the
nucleus
which will be uh transported
into chlorophyll first passing to the
double layer of the claw process
from the tick-tock machinery
laying after entering the stroma
chloroplast
the srp pathway will
deliver the protein into the cycloid
of the chloroplast uh through the
srg5432 and then the exercise
and the receptor and injectors so we
examine
the protein protein direction with y2h
of all the components in
in the pathway with the specular
protein and we find the interactions
but if we there's some reduced
interaction when
the mutant allele uh is used for the
interaction study many of those
directions were what he did with
bifc
so so how how this mutation
is related to to the multiple digit
resistance and the drug tolerance
so we i don't have any evidence we are
still working on it but that's our
speculation
probably because the gene function in
the delivery
particularly for the uh actual cp
proteins which were important for the
photosynthesis
and biogenesis of the synchro membrane
so if the mutation may affect
the transportation of those hcp proteins
which may disturb the photosynthesis so
this is
a a graph
from a review publication
uh indicates in the past ways actually
the photosynthesis system
one system two where the reactive oxygen
species
are produced in different steps
so we speculate
this distributor photosynthesis may
increase the
production of ios so indeed
we we measured the ios
in the mutant and resist a wide
alliance that's called lay by standing
of the oxygen reticle
you can see the much higher level of the
ios in in the mutant line
so here is our hypothesis
basically it's well-known well
established i was involved in almost
all those biotic about
stress tolerance resistances
so this mutation may be relative
with the os production which
may also
uh increase our
basically singling for both robotic
stress tolerance
and uh biotic stress
uh these resistances uh
we we probably include more evidence
that's all
hypothesis so that's all for i
have for the streak examples and first
lastly some of my thoughts or
speculations
so if we have 15 cucumber genes
or candies chronic you can see most of
them are recessive
and they cancel also the strong linkage
particularly for dynamic u and
potentially resistances
and you can see there are very few uh
mbr type
genes so
several years ago there is a review
of the arginines in in
implants that's
as of 2018 there's 314
our genes cloned from plants
which based on the functions and the
model of interactions
they could be classified into nine
classes
broadly speaking uh based on the
uh proposed by the officers they are
perception based
uh there is all those kinases like
error nbr types receptor kinases
receptor proteins
and also the second category is loss of
cesarean genes
and some others so based on these
classifications
the 15 genes we can pop the hundreds
of three for the preception based
uh like the 1k
[Music]
which we cloned recently but didn't
publish that
yet and there are a receptor-like kinase
or mbr type there are four genes belong
to
five genes for the loss of
susceptibility we have the
staggering gene as i just mentioned and
mo
for the protometer resistance and also
the
amino acid transporter gene for the dna
4.13
for others uh
like the wireless resistances
for the i don't know the
spec leave belong to
which category are they located the
percentages
compared with that that in other plants
in all the genes columns so far eighty
percent belong to the perception based
uh receptor-like kinases
receptor-like proteins 15
belong to the loss of susceptible
so we can be a cucumber
with those in other plants you can see
the distribution
very different so that's why i say okay
that's some special things
but why i don't need answers
but here are some few of my speculations
which many of you probably have a better
idea
of course compared with many other
plants one reason baby
we only have 15 genes chronic compared
with
arabidopsis is 157 or more
rice 130 compared to 70 potato 45
the sampling size is too small
which is probably true probably not of
course it's true
there are few mbr genes in the genome
which is
true for all the cuckoo bits
because you have very few
nbr those genes are a lot of reservoirs
new genes for generation of new genes we
don't have in
many numbers so the plants probably have
to
explore other mechanisms and
also i guess the single domestication
and abdominal
skeleton bottleneck and
very limited secondary
tuition secondary general sex company
relatives
and
genetic bases within smart group or
the breathing practice also have
something to do
because it's all a private business
largely
they always focus on a very
narrative genetic base on
gene pool
we don't like resistant sources
in our collection but with the breeding
practice
really use those and unless you have
really
urgent need to explore because of the
breakdown
on you know emerging appearance of new
diseases or new racist strengths
so that progress has something to do
talking about the nbr here is the
philogenetic tree of the quicker pettys
here you can see
through all the quicker beats
species have relatively few
mbr genes uh
most cases 780 but in wider species
like historics and a little remote so
the spawn you go
only anomaly which i'm not sure it's
cracking or not
but you can bear with our own losses 250
to me to 265 rights
even more 535 so that's probably
my main reason another thing which i
have to
say yes the primary gene pool is a
white cucumber cucumber subtitle
cucumber
actually it you have a drink
the freezing flow with cartilage
cucumber
we don't have any real valuable source
of resistance from water cucumber
which is distributed primary india
thailand and the surrounding regions
cucumbers historics is only
species in in cucumbers which have
50 i think 54 species which is actually
compatible
but naturally they're natural you cannot
cross
so let's really limit to the use of the
relatives as a source of resistance
and the cucumber is only species in
cucumbers with only 14 chromosomes all
the rest have
you need for chromosomal 48 chromosomes
so evolutionary speaking
which is very different from like tomato
or potato which have a lot of really
relevant special religious
species so in this sense uh
the floating chromosomes was was
involved from 24
uh consensus through descending display
day
in my opinion it's uh evolutionary
speaking it's a dead dead end for
evolution of a cucumber so that probably
has something to do
so that's all i have for for my talk
lastly i would appreciate that the work
of the pub
today many people contributed including
students graduate students postdocs in
my lab and also
collaborators from both private
and public institutions
my work
is supported by both usda and also from
industry thank you for your attention
uh thank you eating for the presentation
are there any questions
from the audience
how about i start with the first
question
and it is really interesting to
find you clones the state green gene
as a dm resistant gene the state green
normally
know it's involved with delay senses
so do you know in any other crop
for state green genes also involved with
some aspect of disease resistance
yes at the beginning because that's the
first time
some time ago i think uh eruptosis
staggering was showing to be required
for symptom development
and then we find that it contributes
much with these resistance
we are not sure but yes
in soil being michigan state they're
proud that
they published a couple years later i
think the last
year in two years ago
in planet physiology that shows
that in soybeans the staggering also
contribute to
to disease in soybeans
i see so a comment from
mike strength pds
discovers are always the best
right fully agree with you mike and
from rebecca thank you for the wonderful
talk
and again from mike the mechanistic
story involved chlorophyll is impressive
in george they talk
i wonder are there any additional
questions well i do have a common thank
you for
the comments in both staggering
and in the
sparkling cases i think the clock feel
that the photosynthesis pathway
plays an important role i
we we did some preliminary studies and i
we are accumulating evidence
it's just the photosynthesis components
particularly the hcp proteins probably
involved in both cases for for that
resistance
because we see the uh interaction
between the chlorophyll and the lhcp
proteins with both the
staggering and the sparkly proteins
yeah your spec leaf story is really
amazing
so i guess for all the expect
specular leaf for if
they are involved with some resistant
lies they
they should shield the sparkle leave
genotype right
phenotype right uh the speckled
phenotype will be gone
in way in the plant
passes fifth new stage
so i just i'm just
curious if you look at the germplasm
of cucumber say for that
gene is also associated with general
resistance in cucumber or not
oh we don't have we didn't find it there
are different mute
mutants on thus some mutants
show that yellowing or speckle but not
like in aeroblosses i think there are
a lot of mutants called variegation
which very similar to
what we see in cucumber serial killer we
can also call this a variegation mutant
but first they're controlled by
different genes
i haven't seen uh the same gene same
phenotype
in any other plants for this
for the same so there is a question from
mike mike do you want to ask directly
or you want to be ready
i can read it so is the photosynthesis
component important for adaptation first
then it evolved to have a disease
resistance component
second ah
thank you for the question i am not
really
i first i don't think this mutation
from plan not not from reader
perspective from planet perspective they
have any intention
to be associated with diseases
so i
for evolution of perspective yes they're
probably not
but that's the elevated level of
ios is a consequence of the disruptive
photosynthesis system
i'm not sure it has any adaptive
uh consequences for plants
okay great thank you for your answer
uh uh jeff let's go with the shatarias
first shattered do you want to ask
your question directly sure
um yeah yeah thank you for your talk
it's a very nice one and
state grain trade is associated with
drought tolerance in some crops
does this mean that the same gene is
involved with
down emilio resistance and what the
mechanism
is oh sorry staggering is not associated
with drug tolerance
the spak speculative mutation is
staggering is not
okay okay thank you
jeff sure yeah thanks for the talk
i just was intrigued by the the low
number of rg's and you may have said
more about this but
is there anything about the biology of
that family that might
explain why the the low arginine number
is
is true and i was wondering if it's
anything to do with the
autoimmune response that's usually given
or is sometimes given as a
reason for why larger numbers of our
genes are
not beneficial
first there's a low number of
why are gene we are talking about uh in
most cases
talk about nbr yeah right it's it's true
nbr genes relative fuel in the all
cockpit
cf family the reason people speculate
is because we the whole family
lacks of the recent whole genome
duplication
so that that which is true
the whole cook of the family relative
house
except for the cooker pizza uh the
pumpkins
cross but overall even in farming squats
we're even half of the number of nbrs
compared with cucumber or melon
so overall this family has had few
compared with others because lack of the
whole genome duplication that said
as i mentioned it's potentially the
lewis family could explore other
mechanisms
like that receptor-like kinase is really
receptive like
proteins we don't know because so far we
have very few genes
our genes clone it in in the whole
family
but some people speculate
maybe there are more genes for rak or rp
genes
and of course for the simple 15 genes
the unprofessional high numbers of
other categories of the loss of societal
categories
my guess is yes they
because they don't have a lot of our
genes they have to explore other ways
right right yeah no thank you it's an
interesting question
okay so you consider the time the last
question from
rebecca rebecca you want to ask it
directly
uh why is that sorry sorry i'm gonna
double mute it again
i'm sorry um so a couple of questions
really if i can squeeze them in
why do the plants outgrow the speckled
phenotype
and um and also curious and and what
were the leaves actually smaller as they
appeared to be in one of the figures
for that phenotype and then and then
thinking of the stay green is it really
fixing a general defect with the rest of
the germplasm
you know the this excessive buildup of
reactive oxygen is that sort of a
general
problem with the germplasm that you
fixed with that staging it's an
excellent question first for the for the
speculative mutant
it does have some uh i call
side effects or or negative linkage drug
or whatever
yes it it's relatively slow particularly
at the beginning of an earlier stage of
seedling stage
slower small leaves
that's but at the later stage
it against the growth compared with
the wildcard particularly under this
pressure
it definitely it grows much more
hair so faster with
as assuring that it's performed much
better
so why it's called that after like fifth
sleeve
implant there are one class of mutants
called the voracent wasn't
leave or worsen the mutant it's very
common in many plants
like the yellow leaf all the new leaves
should grow
yellow under the the color between green
after
when they become mature or they feel
yellow coca ladens or yellow
they are gone that same is true for the
for the uh speculative
clause spots this is probably
not some series particularly walking
around losses from the
uh works in the leave mutants and
also let's probably have some
interaction
uh during for the chloroplast
uh trans translation
control we are actually working right
but i don't have an immediate answer
for this but it has something to do with
the translation
of the corpus the food machinery
we have some evidence if we use
chemicals to inhibit
other translation
you're going to will be able to retune
the the
phenotype it's going to be gone
and what's your second question
well i was i was wondering if the stay
green
is is really fixing that actual problem
like a mutation or some
some problem that's in the minority the
germplasm where you have that buildup of
reactive oxygen
that's excessive and causing chlorosis
i mean is it better to seen as a as a
mutant or a fix of a mutation
ah
first this mutation yes if
we we did some of the rna
analysis for the staggering
constitutively the photosynthesis
machinery some genes involving
photosynthesis will be definitely
expressed between the
staggering gene and the wall type
but this one will not affect
will not affect the uh the general
performance we don't really see
any significant differences in
performance in growth so
between the staggering mutant and the
wild type
i would say it's uh in this case
it's adaptive trade because this has
been
existing in the wide june plan
collection for a long time
it probably this mutation okay we
also i think it's also relevant to the
ios
elevation elevator ios level
to a fight
that is an infection
which is happened to be explored by by
the plants and defined by the human
being
okay so let's look you consider time
let's
stop here and please join me to
thank you for the wonderful presentation
thanks to you ching thank you all
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu